okay i don't know if you're aware but
your good friend jane aniston she also
stars an executive producer she does
for apple tv plus reach out to her did
she
lend any advice on you know what it's
like uh
starring in ep a series she's doing a
totally different show she's in los
angeles obviously shooting her show and
bopping around uh there so you know it
was
sort of apples and oranges as far as our
productions go but yeah we check in and
you know i think we're both having
fabulous experiences you know
uh working with apple plus you know like
it's
they're really it's that perfect balance
of support
and also not controlling
the the you know the creatives letting
the creatives
and we have an enormous deep bench of
creative people on our show
they don't really they let them do their
job um and
give intelligent notes and it's just
been it's been a really
great set to be on yeah exactly well i'd
love to see justin throw pop on over
there to the morning show
just saying oh listen if there's
something else they want to send me some
pages
hey always open to it good stuff
is gonna be an adventure
i'm scared
absolutely but it didn't feel that way
it wouldn't be an adventure well
congratulations on this series
job well done my friend um series it is
adapted from a best-selling
book that was uh written by none other
than paul thoreau who happens to be your
uncle justin so
that is correct no pressure there buddy
no
yeah yeah but were you at all nervous
about you know taking on family material
and really doing it justice
you know what you'd think so but not
because hey i get along with my uncle
paul
and you know there's whenever you do a
book or any adaptation or something it's
there's always sort of this
invisible wall between you and the
creator and you don't really want to
mess with it you want to obviously be
able to mine them for their ideas and
you don't want to you know but i had
this pre-existing built-in relationship
that i could just pick up the phone call
ask him questions have a coffee with him
you know pick his brain so it was kind
of great it's like having you know
you know living next door to a library
anytime you want to go do some research
that's awesome so you got uncle paul's
seal of approval there
yeah i did i think i hope yeah we'll
it's good stuff man but the book was
also made into a movie back in the 80s
with harrison ford
helen mirren so how did you make your
this character
your own you know put your stamp on it
and was there any pressure in stepping
into the shoes that harrison ford once
felt
you know well i had of course seen uh
the movie with uh harrison um i think
many times
and you know i did my best i never
wanted to and he was fabulous
so i did my best to sort of forget his
performance and just focus on the
material that i was given which is
different than his script obviously um
and then once i saw it i was like there
are similarities
you know um obviously just because
i think when you're given the same
character you're going to come to some
of the same conclusions as an actor
well you knocked it out of the park man
oh thanks we did now
okay if you suddenly needed to to pick
up go on the run
what are the few essentials that you
would take with you what can justin
thoreau
not leave home without and i think you
know what one of them made
you know what one of them is first thing
would be my dog and then i guess
dog food
frustratingly on a walk but she's been
here all day i know justin
i wanted her to meet my guy oh my god
who is that spike say hi to justin mike
what are you doing over there he's just
here fatigue man he's got
webex i'm sure yeah
he's got such fatigue right now dogs are
gonna get like
chafed under their armpits because all
we do is just hold them into the
computer and they just go like this and
i know and i know why are you making me
look at this weird
window i know and he's probably like
entirely bruised because i squeeze him
so much i'm just
around him but okay so obviously kuma uh
some dog food as well now tell me this
who would last longer if you were on the
run out in the wild
you or your girl kuma i mean kuma i
don't know i mean we're so codependent
that
if she died i would surely pass away
immediately and i think vice versa
um you know she'd be fine you know i'll
tell you something she was
homeless and already lived on the
streets for most of her life you know
for
the first two years of her life so she
does really uh she obviously prefers
being at
me but um but she uh i think she'd be
fine
so filming began uh what march 2020
on this production then you guys had to
stop because of the pandemic resume
things in october
so what was it like filming during the
pandemic and then also traveling
throughout mexico
it's gonna sound um uh strange but i
actually loved filming during the
pandemic
um hi hey because i've been in lockdown
in new york for
six months for one and it was just nice
to get out of the house and
make human contact but also our
production did such a fabulous job with
our doctors and immunologists and
you know of testing us all rigorously
every single day and creating a safe
environment for us to work in so it was
kind of
like a breath of fresh air to be able to
to um
to work you know and and to not feel
that constant like
pressure of oh my god we're getting sick
if i'm
around these people um
so there was a safety in it you know and
and it felt fabulous
you know i was actually more bummed that
it was going to end
without won't stop shooting hey because
i was enjoying myself and
b because i was going into a less safe
environment by just going home
now i don't know if you're aware or not
but the film mulholland drive
the 20th anniversary is this year
and of course i know isn't that crazy
now this series has
it serves as like a reunion of sorts
because you started mulholland drive so
does melissa george melissa george is in
this series with you so
how cool was it to reunite the fun of
your coach that was great i mean you
know
we didn't we were obviously in
mulholland but we only had a couple
scenes in that
together and then periodically over the
years i'd see her you know just around
new york or at a party or something like
that
um and and she was always so lovely to
bump into and so sweet
and um and so it was just great and when
we were
casting about looking for uh our margot
uh i sort of had like oh my god what
about melissa george she's a fabulous
actress
and we found her she was living in paris
of all things
so she did a lot more flying than us to
get to set but
um but we're so grateful to have her
come on board yeah well the chemistry is
is dynamic between the two of you
last question because they're asking me
to rap you start sex in the city two
different characters
correct the series is coming back i
don't know if you're aware of that but
it's coming back
would you be down for a third guest role
if so who would you play justin
of course i don't know who i would play
i mean um
i don't know what i don't know what
world they're i mean i'm sex in the city
so i'm
you know sure uh sarah jessica's
probably gonna be in it
i don't know i would i would like to be
another love interest of sarah jessica
i feel like they went through every
actor
in new york city at the time because it
was such a huge show
and i think that's why i got to play two
characters because they just had burned
through everybody and they basically
you know the wheel of fortune came
around to me again i'd love to reprise
one of my roles and see if
or maybe just to come back in a totally
different way